eric girard ministre des finances au
québec me suggéra bonne fin d'après midi
bonjour vous avez dit ce matin qu'on
était dans le pays et de l'inflation en
fait pour les mois de juin moi de me
rejoindre et les pires de l'année pour
l'inflation alors pourquoi ne pas agir
maintenant pourquoi ne pas donner une
aide additionnelle aux québécois
maintenant mais en fait
lorsqu'on a déposé la mise à jour en
novembre
on a posé un geste pour tous ceux qui
gagnent moins de 54 mille dollars en
janvier et au budget de mars nous avons
donné 500 $ à tous ceux qui gagnaient
moins de cent mille dollars et ça
c'était en coordination avec la
déclaration de revenus donc dans les
faits les gens viennent de recevoir une
aide au mois de mai et juin sera
difficile vous l'avez dit vous vous
attendez à ce que sa baisse quand les
taux l'inflation
normalement ce que la plupart des
économistes anticipent c'est que le
sommet on observe maintenant mai juin et
qu'on va avoir une lente décroissance
d'ici la fin de l'année avec le
resserrement des conditions monétaires
des banques centrales mais aussi avec
l'amélioration des situations en chine
parce que vraiment la fermeture de
shanghai là
exacerbait les goulots d'étranglement et
puis là on a quand même des meilleures
nouvelles sur ce front mais je dois dire
qu'on a on n'a pas de bonnes nouvelles
au niveau de la guerre en europe mais
j'essaie toujours de comprendre pourquoi
vous donnez pas une aide à la fois mené
puis à la fois au moment de jouer juste
on veut juste récapituler bout dit le
pire c'est maintenant c'est mois de juin
le poids hier c'est maintenant mais
redonne pas dead ça va baisser au cours
des prochains mois mais là on va vous
donner une aide enfin on va promettre en
campagne électorale une aide quand le
toit coule chez vous monsieur girard est
ce que vous êtes vous vous dites je vais
attendre de réparer en espérant qu'ils
aient pas de pluie qui viennent
mais en fait chez en désaccord avec
votre affirmation parce qu'on vient
d'aider en janvier on vient les aider au
mois de mai et l'or 1 pour calibrer
l'aide de façon adéquate nous avons
besoin de l'ensemble des daims et planer
lorsqu'on or présentement c'est une
moyenne pour les cinq premiers mois de
l'année un taux d'inflation de 6 points
3 % c'est plus élevé que nous avions
prévu mais avant de donner une un pour
compenser pour l'ensemble de l'inflation
en 2022 va falloir avoir plus
d'observations va falloir connaître non
seulement le faudrait connaître au moins
l'ensemble du troisième trimestre mais
déjà planifié monsieur gérard fait me
françois legault a l'air de planifier ce
sera pas une aide ce sera deux aides si
on comprend bien c'est à dire que il
évoque un autre un nouveau chèque on
verra de combien et des baisses d'impôts
dont vous êtes déjà en train de
planifier sans avoir tous les chiffres
non mais mais mais c'est normal qu'on
planifie mais pour garder l'ensemble des
horizons la la compensation il faut
rappeler que le régime fiscal est indexé
au l'indexation pour cette année est
inférieur à l'inflation que nous avions
estimé que nous observons c'est ça qu'on
compense avec des aides ponctuelles pour
le fait que l'inflation est plus élevée
que ce que nous avions prévu ensuite les
baisses d'impôt c'est un geste à long
terme qui vise à redonner aux québécois
du pouvoir d'achat et qui tient compte
du fait que les québécois sont les plus
taxés en amérique du nord mais cela doit
être fait dans le cadre du retour à
l'équilibré budgétaire dans le cas de la
diminution du poids de la dette et
surtout d'un financement adéquat en
santé en éducation donc les baisses
d'impôt c'est sur un horizon plus long
la hausse du coût de la vie ça touche
les québécois maintenant c'est pour ça
qu'on a agi en janvier c'est pour ça
qu'on a agi au mois de mai et c'est pour
ça qu'on devrait agir puisque
l'inflation et hulot plus élevé que
prévu ok médoc ce que vous nous dites
c'est que dans les provinces électeurs
de la coalition bois québec il y aura
des baisses d'impôts
je ne dévoile pas le programme électoral
aujourd'hui il ya des étapes
présentement moi je prépare le rapport
pré électorales d'ici la fin juin qui
sera transmis à la vérificatrice
générale pour qu'ils
l'analyse il y apporte son évaluation
ces commentaires se sera divulgué le 15
ou ça va donner l'heure juste aux
québécois sur l'ensemble la situation
économique et du cadre financier ça va
permettre à l'ensemble des partis
politiques de faire des promesses
électorales basé sur un cadre financier
neutre non partisan et tous les partis
pourront choisir les priorités qu'ils
veulent présenter aux québécois dans
notre corps remettre de l'argent aux
québécois c'est ce que nous avions
promis en 2010 us c'est ce que nous
avons fait avec la taxe scolaire les
allocations famille et on va continuer
de le faire oui et donc je reviens vous
dit pas de l'argent pour le mois de juin
mais on en a donné au mois de mai est ce
que le 500 $ du mois de mai est à votre
avis suffisant pour contrer
l'augmentation de l'inflation au gré en
fait tout est relatif lorsqu'on la
notion moins de marciano qui disait que
c'était trop il y en a qui disait qu il
ils n'en voulaient pas y en a qui disait
qu'on ne veut pas le donner à
6.4 millions de personnes il faut
regarder l'ensemble des gestes que nous
posons à la mise à jour on annonce et
275 $ pour une personne seule qui
gagnaient moins de 53 me au budget de
mars 500 $ pour tous ceux qui gagnent
moins de cent mille dollars on a aussi à
aider les aînés de plus de 70 ans à
faible revenu donc dans l'ensemble on ne
plus donner à ceux qui gagnent moins on
a visé avec le 500 dollars une mesure
d'application générale et l'on va
observer le comportement de l'inflation
qui vont suivre dans le reste de l'année
et puis on voit pondéré notre aide en
fonction de l'influx de la réalisation
d'inflation pourquoi pas baisser les
taxes monsieur byden suspens en fait
pourquoi ne pas suspendre les taxes joe
biden suspens ni taxe sur l'essence
l'alberta l'a fait aussi pourquoi on en
fait pas au québec mais parce que lorsqu
on baisse les taxes sur l'essence on n'a
aucune garantie que savoir ça va être
remis aux consommateurs c'est à dire que
cela les baisses de taxes peuvent aller
d'une part dans les les marges des
raffineurs les marges de haute saône
erreur une erreur aux états unis de fait
je laisse les américains choisir les
politiques qu'ils qu'il désire pour
leurs citoyens moi j'analyse l'ensemble
des propositions et c'est certain que si
on modifie le fait que le prix de
l'essence augmente on dit que lorsque le
prix augmente de 10% la demande baisse
d'un pour cent alors si on empêche les
fêtes substitution on n'aide pas
les incitations à consommer de l'essence
est en baisse les taxes ce sont bien ces
taxes on encourage la consommation le
centre c'est certain d'accord donc vous
irez pas dans cette direction non on
fait confiance aux québécois c'est à
dire que nous on a choisi de donner une
indirects les québécois peuvent
déterminer ce qui est important pour eux
soit le panier de consommation le panier
d'épicerie soins soit de soins plus de
consommation d'essence mais ça peut être
aussi rembourser des dettes seul c'est
ce taux québécois choisir leurs
priorités monsieur gérard merci beaucoup
de plaisir merci beaucoup